S
IS "THE FIVE."
DEMOCRACY APPARENTLY GOING TO
END IN SIX DAYS IF YOU DON'T
VOTE FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN WILL BE GIVING A
LAST MINUTE SPEECH LATER TONIGHT
ON PRESERVING AND PROTECTING OUR
DEMOCRACY.
BECAUSE HE'S GOT NOTHING ELSE TO
RUN ON.
BIDEN FLIPPING BACK A FEW
CHAPTERS IN HIS PLAYBOOK TO THE
ONE ABOUT MAGA REPUBLICANS BEING
EVIL AND ONLY HIS PARTY CAN SAVE
THE SOUL OF THE NATION.
OUR VERY OWN SLB, PETER DOOCY,
CHALLENGING THE WHITE HOUSE
ABOUT WHAT THE PRESIDENT WILL
SAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS LONG TALKED
ABOUT OUR NATION BEING AT AN
INFLECTION POINT.
HE HAS BEEN CLEAR DEMOCRACY IS
UNDER ASSAULT.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE SEEN MEGA
MAGA ARE PUBLIC AND OFFICIALS
WHO DON'T BELIEVE IN THE RULE OF
LAW.
>> DOES THAT MEAN
PRESIDENT BIDEN THINGS AS A
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY SOMEBODY
VOTES REPUBLICAN?
>> NO.
THAT'S A RIDICULOUS QUESTION.
NO.
>> WHY IS THAT A RIDICULOUS
QUESTION?
>> AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
THE RIGHT TO VOTE FOR WHOMEVER
THEY WANT.
THE VOTING IS A SACRED RIGHT.
IT IS SOMETHING THE PRESIDENT
WANTS TO PROTECT.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN THINKS
DEMOCRACY CAN SURVIVE EVEN IF
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT IN CHARGE OF
CONGRESS?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS OPTIMISTIC.
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN GEARS UP
TO ATTACK LITERALLY EVERY
REPUBLICAN ON THE BALLOT,
HILLARY CLINTON SAYS "HOLD MY
BEER," BY INSULTING VOTERS.
SPEAK ARE YOU CONCERNED VOTERS
AREN'T PUTTING THOSE PIECES
TOGETHER, HAVING REPUBLICAN
HOUSE WOULD MEAN THE PUBLIC
TRICKLE PEOPLE YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT WOULD BE MORE EMPOWERED.
>> WITH ALL THE NOISE THAT WE
HAVE GOT IN THIS ELECTION
SEASON, I DON'T THINK PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO REALLY GRASP THAT.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, I'M NOT SURE
THEY REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
THREATS TO THEIR WAY OF LIFE.
>> Jesse: DANA, THE STRATEGY
BEHIND GOING OUT.
THIS SEEMS HAPHAZARD TO ME.
>> Dana: YES.
I THINK THEY GOT SOME NUMBERS
OVERNIGHT.
THEY SAW THAT BARACK OBAMA IS
OUT THERE ARE THE ONLY ONE
GETTING CROWDS, THE ONLY ONE
GETTING DEMOCRATS SOMEWHAT
EXCITED TO COME SEE THEM BUT
THEN THEY REALIZE THAT HE'S NOT
ON THE BALLOT AND THEY GET THEIR
NUMBERS OVERNIGHT ON THE
WHITE HOUSE IN THE MORNING IS
LIKE "WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING.
THEY HAVE A BRAINSTORMING
SESSION, WHAT SHOULD WE DO.
LAST WEEK IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THEY SAID
RELATIVE TO TURNOUT IN 2018
THERE HAS BEEN A SURGE OF
PARTICIPATION FROM WOMEN, BLACK
VOTERS AND VOTERS OVER THE AGE
OF 50.
THIS IS WHO THEY ARE TRYING TO
GO FOR.
THAT WAS IN GEORGIA.
THEY ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY, HOW CAN WE MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE IS PAYING ATTENTION TO
THIS.
HOWEVER.
FIRST OF ALL LET ME TALK ABOUT
THE SETTING.
UNION STATION?
THAT WAS MY FAVORITE PLACE TO GO
WHEN I FIRST MOVED TO WASHINGTON
IN 1995.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL,
MARBLE COLUMNS, THE COOLEST
FOOD COURT, THE STARBUCKS THAT
YOU COULD GO TO, FANCY
RESTAURANTS AND YOU KNOW WHAT IT
IS TODAY?
A COMPLETE AND TOTAL HELLSCAPE.
TAKEN OVER BY THE HOMELESS, DRUG
ADDICTS.
IT'S LIKE PENN STATION.
I'M KIND OF CURIOUS.
WHAT IS THE BACKDROP THEY ARE
GOING TO USE?
REMEMBER THE FIRST MEGA MAGA
SPEECH.
WHY DO THEY THINK THIS IS GOING
TO WORK?
THE STARBUCKS LEFT THE UNION
STATION.
THE OTHER THING IS IT'S RIGHT
THERE IN THE CORRIDOR.
WHO IS HE TALKING TO?
HE'S NOT TALKING TO
WORKING-CLASS VOTERS, NOT
TALKING TO PEOPLE SAYING WE ARE
WORRIED ABOUT CRIME, THE BORDER,
EDUCATION, INFLATION.
IS THERE SOMETHING YOU CAN DO TO
HELP US?
NO.
HE IS GOING TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
WHAT HE SHOULD HAVE DONE
INSTEAD.
>> Greg: DON'T DO IT YET.
>> Dana: WHY?
>> Greg: THEY ARE WATCHING.
>> Dana: IT'S TOO LATE.
EVEN IF HE WAS GOING TO GET
BOOED, HE AND THE FIRST LADY
SHOULD'VE GONE TO GAME 4 OF THE
PHILLIES-ASTROS SERIES AND THEN
THERE LIKE A REGULAR JOE.
INSTEAD HE IS GOING TO GIVE A
LECTURE ABOUT THE ELECTION.
>> Jesse: COULD'VE GONE THE
THROUGHOUT THE FIRST PITCH.
>> Dana: REALLY WOULD'VE
GOTTEN BOOED.
>> Jesse: IS THIS GOING TO BE
ANOTHER MEGA MAGA, ULTRA MAGA,
TRICKLE DOWN TO BE 25 DEAL.
>> Dana: HILLARY DID NOT LOOK
WELL.
IT APPEARS SHE MIGHT HAVE THROWN
UP ON JOY REID'S SHIRT.
HE'S PROBABLY GOING TO MENTION
JANUARY 6TH BECAUSE THAT'S ALL
WE EVER CONVENTION BECAUSE HE
HAS NOTHING ELSE.
JANUARY 6 HAS BECOME THE KEVIN
BACON OF TERRIBLE EVENTS FOR
DEMOCRATS.
EVERYTHING COULD BE LINKED TO
JANUARY 6.
I JUST HOPE WHEN HE BRINGS UP
ELECTION DENIERS WHICH IS A
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY HE DOES
INCLUDE DEAR HILLARY WHO ALREADY
CALLED INTO QUESTION 2024 SO WE
BETTER INCLUDE THAT.
IT'S AMAZING HOW EXTREME THE
DEMONIZATION HAS BECOME.
IT'S A TRIP.
YOU'RE WATCHING THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO CLAIMED RHETORIC BECAUSE THE
PELOSI VIOLENCE.
THEN MAYOR MINUTES LATER IN
ANOTHER SEGMENT WE WILL SAY
REPUBLICANS ARE A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY.
IF THE REPUBLICANS TAKE OVER AND
WE HAVE HEARD THIS, WORSE THAN
9/11, WATERGATE, WORSE THAN CNN
PLUS ALL COMBINED.
WHO IS PAINTING TARGETS ON WHO?
WHEN THEY SAY IT'S PRINTED
DEMOCRACY, THEY ARE REALLY
SAYING IT'S A THREAT TO
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE OF THE ONLY
TIME THEY FEEL A SENSE OF
URGENCY, WHEN THEY ARE ABOUT TO
BE TOSSED OUT OF POWER AND YOU
LOOK AT WHAT THEY CALL A THREAT
TO DEMOCRATS OR A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY, VOTER I.D.,
FREE SPEECH WHICH IS NOW BEING
REDEFINED AS DISINFORMATION,
ELON MUSK BUYING TWITTER.
SOMEHOW THAT'S GOING TO END THE
WORLD.
FOX NEWS WHICH PRESENTS A FAIR
AND BALANCED VIEW OF THE NEWS
WHICH HAS SO LONG BEEN BIASED
AND WHAT'S NOT A THREAT TO THEM,
CRIME.
IF YOU BRING UP CRIME, THEY MAKE
FUN OF YOU.
RIOTS, LOOTING, SOCIAL JUSTICE.
THEY PUT THEMSELVES IN A CORNER
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN DEMONIZING
PEOPLE FOR SO LONG THEY DON'T
KNOW WHERE TO GO ON THE
PRESIDENT'S CREDIBILITY IS --
HE IS --
HE COMES OFF AS ANGRY,
HABITUALLY LYING AND CONFUSED.
HE IS LIKE AN OLD CONFIDENCE MAN
IN THE MEDICINE SHOW DITCHED HIM
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT AND
HE IS STUCK IN YOUR TOWN.
>> Jesse: KATIE, ONE
REPUBLICANS END DEMOCRACY OF THE
RED --
AFTER THE RED WAVE, IS BIDEN
SAYING THERE IS NEVER GOING TO
BE ANOTHER HOUSE AND SENATE
ELECTION?
ALL OF THE SENATORS AND
CONGRESSMEN ARE JUST GOING TO
SIT IN THEIR OFFICES AND YOU'RE
NEVER GOING TO GET THEM OUT OF
THERE?
>> Katie: IS HARD TO KNOW WHAT
BIDEN IS SAYING SO I DON'T KNOW
WHY YOU'RE ASKING ME TO DEFINE
SOME OF THE THINGS HE'S BEEN
SAYING.
I USED IT TO GET LUNCH IN
UNION STATION.
NOW I GET MY STREET CRED THERE.
REPUBLICANS ARE HAVING BIG
RALLIES.
REGISTERING MORE VOTERS AND THEY
ARE LOSING THE EARLY VOTING
BATTLE IN PLACES LIKE FLORIDA
AND GEORGIA FOR EXAMPLE AND
POSSIBLY IN PENNSYLVANIA AS WELL
SO THAT'S WHY THEY ARE DOING
THIS.
DEMOCRATS HAVE INVESTED SO MUCH
POLITICAL CAPITAL, INCLUDING THE
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE COME INTO
THIS NARRATIVE ABOUT PRESERVING
DEMOCRACY.
REPUBLICANS ARE A THREAT TO
THEY ARE CLAIMING IF REPUBLICANS
GO TO THE POLLS OR INDEPENDENT
VOTERS FOR EXAMPLE AND VOTE FOR
REPUBLICANS THAT IT'S A THREAT
TO DEMOCRACY EVEN THOUGH THEY
ARE LITERALLY VOTING FOR
REPRESENTATIVES THEY BELIEVE
WILL REPRESENT WHAT THEY WANT
AND TAKE CARE OF THE ISSUES THAT
ARE AFFECTING THEIR LIVES.
IN JUNE, FOX NEWS DID A POLL.
THEY ASK THE QUESTION, WHO DO
YOU THINK IS BETTER AT
PRESERVING DEMOCRACY,
REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS.
REPUBLICANS WON BY ONE POINT.
THEY STILL WON.
AFTER ALL THE POLITICAL CAPITAL
AND ENDLESS HOURS THEY'VE SPENT
ON THIS INCLUDING THE SPEECH IN
PHILADELPHIA AND THE SPEECH
TONIGHT.
COUNTLESS STATEMENTS FROM
LAWMAKERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
THIS IS THE NARRATIVE THEY USE
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
IT'S NOT WORKING AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO WORK ON THE WEDNESDAY
NIGHT BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> Jesse: THE GUY WHO WAS
SUPPOSED TO SAVE DEMOCRATS,
BARACK OBAMA, UNDER A DESK.
WATCH THIS.
>> MONDAY NIGHT AND HERE'S WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING UNDER MY
DESK?
>> UNDER THE DESK IS KIND OF MY
THING.
>> YOU CAN STAY FOR NOW BUT WHEN
IT COMES TIME TO VOTING YOU'RE
GOING HAVE TO GET UP.
YOU HAVE CLIMATE CHANGE
LEGISLATION ON THE BALLOT.
YOU HAVE GUN SAFETY.
AND WE CAN ELECT MORE PRO-CHOICE
NUMBERS OF CONGRESS.
WE CAN REINSTITUTE ROE VS. WADE
IS THE LAW OF THE LAND.
YOU CAN'T STAY HERE.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO VOTE.
>> Jesse: REMEMBER MY RULE
AGAINST MEN EATING ICE CREAM IN
PUBLIC?
ONLY ON VACATION.
MENTION ALSO NEVER SIT ON THE
GROUND.
EVER.
UNLESS YOU'RE PLAYING WITH YOUR
CHILD, YOU SHOULD NEVER --
>> Dana: NOT EVEN THEN.
>> Jesse: OR YOUR DOG.
HIS >> Greg: NO.
NEVER SIT ON THE GROUND.
>> Jesse: INDIAN STYLE?
>> Greg: CRISSCROSS.
DO YOU THINK YOU ARE LIZ WARREN?
>> Jesse: CRISSCROSS
APPLESAUCE.
>> Jessica: I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
DOING.
YOU ARE EATING MY TIME.
BARACK OBAMA DOING GET OUT THE
VOTE STUFF IS FINE WHEN HE SAT
BETWEEN TWO FRIENDS AND HAD THAT
CONVERSATION, ALSO FINE.
HE IS THE HERO OF THE MIDTERM
CYCLE AND I'M HAPPY HE'S OUT
THERE.
HE'S HEADED TO ARIZONA NEXT.
HE WASN'T GOING TO DO THIS MUCH
CAMPAIGNING.
WE NEED HIM.
THEN JACOBS HAS A NEW PIECE OUT
AND HE WENT TO A LEAN GLORIOUS
DISTRICT, ONE OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE DEMOCRATS IN
VIRGINIA.
HE WENT THERE TO SEE IF ANYBODY
CARED ABOUT JANUARY 6TH AND THEY
DON'T.
THIS IS SOMEONE BEING
REPRESENTED BY SOMEONE WHO WAS
THE MAIN QUESTION ON THE FINAL
PRIME TIME NIGHT.
THAT CONCERNS ME THAT TONIGHT
THAT WILL BE OUR TOPIC AND I
KNOW THAT IT'S A MESSY IDEA AND
DANA WAS MUCH MORE THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT GOING TO THE WORLD SERIES.
I WOULD LIKE A DO-OVER SPEECH.
IF PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID I AM
COMING OUT AND I'M GOING TO DO
ALL THE THINGS I'VE HEARD THAT
I'VE DONE WRONG, I'M GOING TO
ADDRESS CRIME.
I'M GOING TO TALK ABOUT
INFLATION IN REAL TERMS.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU HAVE PLANS
FOR ALL THESE THINGS.
REPUBLICANS WILL NOT MEET THE
MOMENT WHEN IT COMES TO THEM FOR
X, Y, AND Z REASONS.
PEOPLE ARE FORGIVING.
PEOPLE GENERALLY LIKE HIM, ALSO
CERTAINLY DEMOCRATS, A LOT OF
INDEPENDENCE, SOME MODERATE
REPUBLICANS CONCERNED ABOUT
REPUBLICANS TAKING OVER AGAIN SO
I AM FOR THE KITCHEN SINK
SPEECH.
WANT TO TALK ABOUT JANUARY 6, I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
I THINK CORE DEMOCRATIC VOTERS
DO THINK THAT.
BUT TALK ABOUT THE OTHERS STUFF,
OUR BACKS AGAINST THE WALL IN
NEW YORK, PENNSYLVANIA,
WISCONSIN.
SHOW VOTERS THAT WE ARE ON THE
FENCE ABOUT YOU WHEN WE ARE
STILL DECIDING.
THAT YOU'VE HEARD THEM AND YOU
RECOGNIZE THEIR REAL-LIFE
CONCERNS.
>> Dana: HE WANTS THE AMNESTY
SPEECH.
>> Jesse: I CAN'T BELIEVE I
MISSED BACKBEND JACOBS PEACE.
>> Greg: IT'S AMAZING.
I READ IT FOUR TIMES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jessica: THAT'S UNNECESSA